when talking to college-bound students
it has been quite striking to me how the
notion of financial trade-offs
is so often absent from the
decision-making process
there are indeed reasonable
non-financial factors to consider
but they seem to play an outsized role
students who value aesthetic factors
aren't naive by nature they're simply a
product of a culture that has over
emphasized romantic notions about
college
this culture tends to discourage
aspiring students from being critical
consumers
here's what you can do about that first
use
data to support your decision making and
with those data
compare the benefits you expect from
your degree to the cost for each college
you're considering
finally understand that colleges are
businesses too
and that they still have balance sheets
and bills to pay my point isn't to ruin
the fun of those who feel sentimental
about this important decision
but rather to lessen future regret
weighing the benefits against the cost
is the best way to accomplish that what
factors did you consider
when picking your college let us know in
our poll
also let us know what other topics you'd
like us to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to subscribe for more
research and videos from aei